you know with the like event having
lately how much you want to bet this is
the video that you to doesn't Barry hey
everybody I found myself in a bit of an
odd situation especially with the timing
of the release of this because yesterday
I put out my voice the youtubers burnout
video which I shot like a month ago and
just didn't put out till now since it
was kind of an evergreen topic it was
one of those things that I kind of just
kept in my back pocket for a bit and now
I find myself doing a kind of a
spiritual follow-up to that I don't know
why nobody's gonna see this which is the
problem my channel has been tanked I
don't know why I noticed it on Wednesday
that views were way way down on the
overdue Doctor Who now initially what I
thought had happened because something
had got weird the last time before that
that I had set up a video initially as
unlisted so that I could provide the
link on patreon so they would get early
access to it
and something had gone we had last time
I did it so I assumed on Wednesday
that's something that it went weird cuz
I tried to do that again I might find
heck with it I'm not gonna do that
clear to re-uploaded it and it still did
awful when I say awful I mean like so
Sunday and Monday of last week were not
great but they were also kind of off
topic for me you know talking about ds9
talking about Superman they did about
what I expected them to
and then coming into overdue Doctor Who
that video did in the first 24 hours
maybe a quarter of what it would have
done normally and I honestly didn't know
what to make of that and then the video
went up on Friday which was the Disney
characters into Hogwarts houses and on a
whim I even did that one as a premiere
to see if that would counteract whatever
the heck was going on didn't and it's
clearly not an issue of like Doctor Who
not being a trending topic anymore
because this was a completely different
topic and the numbers were even worse
and I've been alerted and a lot of the
comments on both those videos bear out
people aren't seeing my videos are not
showing up in subscription feeds or
recommendations they're just not the
videos are still there if you go to my
channel if you follow ad elect link like
say what I post on Twitter or the
Facebook page or the patreon page you
can get to it so they're not deleted
they're not blocked but nobody is seeing
that they're going up unless they are
set up with the bail and they get a
notification but even people set up with
the bail if they go to their
subscription feed it's not there they
even those people still have to go to my
channel to even see that it exists much
less watch it so I don't think this is
in any way targeted I don't think like
YouTube has like shadow banned me or
something if you're not familiar with
that term usually is a term on Instagram
where an account is not technically
blocked but it is basically taken out of
the algorithms for suggestions and and
show up in people's feeds and I don't
think anything like that has had
and here or if it has I don't believe it
to be intentional because YouTube has
owned up to a certain amount of things
being very wonky because like a lot of
places right now they've had to cut down
on their on-site work staff did too you
know for the sake of not having stuff
get worse and spread further so they had
sent out some heads-up like hey some
things may be off the specific thing
that they addressed were that videos
that do not deserve to be may end up
being blocked or deleted because of how
many things are now being automated by
BOTS that normally would have had gone
on past the desk of a human you know at
some point the process and now they
aren't none of the things at least that
I could find that they've been like hey
heads up this might happen
involved just being bottom doubt like
it's happening to me we're like nobody
sees your stuff but it's still there now
I'm not gonna say I've never heard of
this happening before I have like I
remember back a year year and a half
maybe even two years ago when the Bell
was first introduced definitely a number
the youtubers I subscribed to part of
what they were saying with why you need
to hit the bell is because not everyone
was seeing stuff showing up in their
subscription feeds so I've seen that as
an issue obviously when there have been
ad pocalypse shifts in the algorithm
some people's views went way down and
but I've never had any of that happened
to me and I and from what I can see
looking around I'm not seeing my direct
experience reflected a lot of other
places at least not that I could find to
the degree that I'm prepared to dig
around and look for it because honestly
I'm am NOT the best at research and be
it's depressing so
I don't know what's causing it and I
don't know how to address it I don't
know if it can be addressed even if
YouTube wasn't operating on skeleton
crew this I channel my size this isn't
something that I would expect to be able
to get much direct help on under the
best of circumstances and now like
forget it so here's where things stand
with me right now I don't plan to slow
down and I don't plan to stop because I
love doing this but I'm not gonna lie
this is really disheartening and it's
not even a case of oh I'm not getting as
many views as I as I did when you know
my channel was more topical because
there was new Doctor Who airing it
wasn't I've dealt with that before and
that's disheartening in its own way this
is a whole other ballgame even the
people who have you know told told
YouTube subscribe want to know when this
person post things aren't seeing it now
let me be clear as far as overall things
that like I'm I'm dealing with a lot I'm
very stressed but so are most people I
solved my job you know that hasn't
changed so I'm not in any kind of a dire
situation because this is not the primer
my primary source of income it's not the
main way of payment bills that having
been said it is an important supplement
and this is the time of year where her
sudden drop in income is not ideal not
that it's ever ideal but so you know
there are some times where you can
cushion it better this isn't great but I
intend to keep my schedule as planned I
plan to keep moving forward because I
still I still have my patreon supporter
love people going out of their way to
support me who deserve my regular output
and I will continue to do that
but first thing is apologies if my
overall tone of deliver delivery gets a
little more somber I'm gonna try to not
have this enter into how I present but
it's just it's hard to battle off the
thought of well what's the freaking
point because as much as I love doing
this and as much as I have always said
don't get into this game if you wouldn't
love doing it even when nobody's
watching and I stand by that but it's
one thing when you start out and you're
doing it and nobody's watching but
you're slowly having more people watch
it and then for that to suddenly vanish
that is a different scenario like I said
I'm gonna try a few other things there's
a few elements and features of YouTube
that I don't currently use by can and I
have no reason no actual active reason
to believe that this is actually gonna
counteract what I'm dealing with but I
would like to know that I've tried
everything so I'm probably gonna start
I've had it like halfway done for a
while now I'm probably gonna activate
YouTube memberships which was something
I was dragging my feet on because I
worked very hard on having it be more or
less equivalent to the patreon so people
who choose to either support me that way
or on the patreon aren't getting
substantively different experiences
wanted to make them as close and
approximate as I can but I'll probably
activate that after having recorded this
but before this goes up I'll have put up
new videos on the breakroom of geeks and
the very wild channel we'll see if those
are
tanked as much as this channel is
obviously those channels get lower views
anyway but I still know I still know
what is low by the standards of those
channels so I can at least give a sense
of whether it's only this channel or not
I might end up you know pushing out more
stuff in the break room to get that over
the the hump so that can be monetized to
try and counteract the fact that
nobody's seeing me right now on here and
I wish I had like a grand concluding
statement but honestly this is me just
kind of giving you an update and my
plans for how to deal with this are
half-formed and probably won't make a
difference so like I don't need to be a
downer
I really don't especially like now like
nobody needs me to be a downer right now
and I like is that I'm gonna but I'm
gonna try very hard to not have that
Sully the tone of my videos I want to
make stuff that people want to see and
can make them smile while all this is
going on of course it would help if they
could actually see it so that's where
I'm at right now
it's where the channels at it's how it's
the latest way that I'm being completely
screwed by I don't know what to blame
the algorithm the bots something so it
goes I'll see you folks tomorrow for the
live stream where I'm gonna open up the
birthday presents that people sent me so
I think that'll have a nice little later
tone that'll be fun and stop in then
it's
7:00 p.m. Eastern Time
unless I shift it to a little bit later
I don't know you keep an eye out and
that'll wrap it up for this one stop in
say hi I'd appreciate it but you don't
have to end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just trying to
run these meetings if people can make it
and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]